[Music]
breaking news tonight tiger woods
undergoes surgery after a serious car
crash
and i just hope he's all right his
injuries how his vehicle veered off the
road
can the golfing great who has overcome
so much come through
this also on this tuesday night a
virtual meeting between trudeau
and biden where they see eye to eye and
where
they differ ominous pandemic predictions
all of these pieces really are
suggesting that there is a storm
brewing where kovit 19 could soon spiral
out of control
and prescribing the great outdoors
it just calms everything down harnessing
the healing power
of parks
national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with a serious car crash
involving
one of the world's best known athletes
tiger woods the 45 year old golfer is in
the hospital in los angeles tonight
where he has undergone emergency surgery
this is the aftermath of the single
vehicle crash his agent says woods has
multiple injuries to his legs
it happened south of l.a woods was alone
in the car
police say it crossed the median hit
some trees and rolled down an embankment
woods was conscious when they arrived
and in serious but stable condition
he had to be extricated through the
windshield
we used a halogen tool which is a tool
used for prying
and we also used an ax to pry
him from the vehicle he was taken from
the vehicle with
seat a collar and backboard for spinal
precautions it was my understanding that
it
serious injuries to both legs
i asked him what his name was he told me
his name was tiger at that moment i
immediately recognized him
i asked him if he knew where he was what
time of day just to make sure he was
oriented
he seemed as though he was lucid and
calm even if you don't play golf you
know the name
tiger woods he dominated the sport for
years at the same time as his troubled
personal life made headlines
he has overcome multiple surgeries
including a fifth back
operation recently tonight his future is
again
in doubt eric sorenson has our top story
it is a sickening sight the demolished
wreck of a car that carried one of the
greatest athletes in sports history
tiger woods and the news doesn't get
better police say woods the lone
occupant
in a vehicle that sustained major damage
his agent saying woods suffered multiple
leg injuries
and was undergoing surgery this
afternoon justin thomas is a top golfer
and a friend of tiger woods i'm sick to
my stomach
you know it hurts to see one of your
i mean now my closest friends
you know getting an accident and man i
just hope he's all right
just just worry for his kids you know
i'm sure they're struggling
woods had just had his fifth back
surgery and spoke of it this week
i'm still in the gym still doing
the mundane stuff that you have to do
for
rehab so tiger seven weeks from today
final round of the masters you're going
to be there
god i hope so i got to get there first
as a sports superstar woods almost
single-handedly elevated the game of
golf to one of the most lucrative and
popular sports in the world
he won the 1997 masters by an
astonishing 12 strokes
and went on to set record after record
then
he had a very public marriage breakdown
and as he got older
with injuries he played less often so
when he stormed a victory in the 2019
masters
22 years after his first win it was an
achievement that only brightened an
already incandescent career
here it is the return to glory
tigers shot a round of golf with
basketball star dwyane wade just
yesterday
how how good am i or how bad am i uh
good
i'm not good i'm sorry for you we're
getting better
sports titans have reacted jack nicklaus
writes
we are deeply concerned we want to offer
him our heartfelt support
and magic johnson writes everyone send
your prayers out to tiger woods
the fact that woods is in his 40s and
has had serious back injuries before
does not bode well for a recovery that
could see him return to competitive golf
there were still more records ahead to
challenge tiger woods
tonight it's not clear he will have the
chance to break them
erik sorensen global news toronto
now turning to the state of the
relationship with canada's closest
neighbor and biggest trading partner
prime minister justin trudeau has just
finished meeting with the american
president joe biden
it is the first time they've met since
biden took office
this was more than a get to know you the
two men have an existing
relationship that began when biden was
barack obama's vice president
trudeau was the first foreign leader to
call and congratulate biden on his
victory over donald trump last fall and
this was their chance to reset after
those four
unpredictable trump years our chief
political correspondent david aiken
is with me david there are areas where
there is clear alignment
including on climate policy let's start
with the positives in this meeting
well you named it climate change is the
obvious one and was tonight donna
biden is clearly signaling that he wants
america to lead on this fell and you
know what
justin trudeau couldn't be happier we're
also going to talk about climate change
and thank you again for stepping up in
such a big way
on tackling climate change u.s
leadership has been
sorely missed over the past past years
but the other big positive here for
canada and trudeau hinted at it
is that the trudeau government is
working with the white house
that no longer has donald trump in it
there was no drama today there's no
tweet storms running around after that
meeting
and in a sign that the biden
administration is recommitting the u.s
to global cooperation
biden this evening announced that a
joint cabinet-level task force will be
set
to address joint climate change action
donna
so back to a regular friendship david
what about the irritants though in the
relationship
in particular biden's buy america policy
yes and there are irritants in the
relationship but in their statements
tonight after the meeting
they really did not dwell on them a buy
america policy certainly that
discriminates against canadian companies
could be a big problem for trudeau and
on the u.s side
america still does not think canada
spends enough on defense but that's
about it donna
what about china david the entire
liberal cabinet including the prime
minister abstained from a house of
commons vote yesterday on declaring
what china is doing to the uyghur
muslims genocide
trudeau says he'd prefer a broad
consensus among western allies
did he ask for president biden's help on
dealing with china
i think he may have they certainly did
talk about china and in fact
the u.s president joe biden declared his
strong support
for the two canadians in jail in china
let me reiterate our support for the
release
of the detained chinese associates
detained in
china two canadians michael spavar
and michael coving covering excuse me
human beings are not bartering ships
you know we're going to work together
until we get their safe return
now the u.s president might have mangled
that statement a bit but the intent was
pretty clear donna and having the white
house
very solidly on canada's side in this
matter could be a big help
but more broadly canada and the us this
evening declaring
that they will join forces when it comes
to advancing their economic interests
when it comes to china and they will
push china on the uyghurs
hong kong democracy activists and other
human rights issues
okay david aiken in ottawa thank you
here's a reminder of the plight of
michael coverig and michael spavor they
were arrested december 10th of 2018 and
they've been in custody
for 806 days consular officials have
been given access to coverig 20 times
and to spavor
19 times but there have been no
in-person visits with either man since
mid-january of 2020 when the covet-19
pandemic took hold and
all contact with the two michaels was
cut off beijing allowed virtual visits
to resume in october last year
and last month it agreed to grant
consular officials
and family greater though still limited
access
to the men and china is unhappy after
the house
of commons voted to call china's
persecution of uyghur muslims
genocide
that is a spokesman for china's foreign
ministry he said the motion disregards
facts and common sense and
purposely smears china china is accused
of the mass detention of uyghurs in
so-called re-education camps
accused of carrying out acts of torture
and forced sterilization
266 mps from all parties voted in favor
of the genocide designation
prime minister trudeau and his entire
cabinet abstained from the vote
the resolution is non-binding now
to the vaccination campaign here in
canada thousands of doses are being
delivered this week and the promise from
ottawa is still
that every canadian who wants a vaccine
against covet 19
will get one by september if all goes
according to plan
6 million doses will have arrived by the
end of march
that jumps to 29 million by june 30th
and at least 84 million doses of the two
vaccines approved for use in canada
are expected by the end of september the
prime minister has been assured by the
premiers
they have the resources needed to get
all of those doses administered
abigail beeman tells us what we know and
don't know about the plans in canada's
two
biggest provinces do you think it's
taking too long
damn right it is i'm disappointed
there's people in the states of my age
who have already received their vaccines
many quebec seniors are stuck waiting i
take it when it comes
she's a tough bird at 86 ulla von bauer
is one of about 200 thousand who can
register for the vaccine as of thursday
if you're over 85 you'll be able to make
an appointment
with limited supply experts say the plan
makes sense all you need is someone's
birthday
it avoids some of the more complicated
risk algorithms that have been proposed
the virus is ageist it preys on the
people that are at the extremes of age
the older you are the higher your risk
of hospitalization and death
next door ontario faces criticism for
not always ensuring the most vulnerable
or prioritized
we were actually seeing workers in
hospital who aren't
actually high-risk front-line workers
actually getting vaccinated a strategy
that really is focused on speed over
precision
that actually frankly has unfortunately
led to a lot of
ontarians unnecessarily losing their
lives why is there such such confusion
around the vaccine criticism too over a
lack of specifics
we now know ontario's 34 local public
health units could have
34 different roll-out plans each
responsible for leading their own
vaccination
efforts there are many different ways
that this is going to be rolled out and
this is going to be made clear to the
people of ontario
in a very short while it's actually
probably the best plan
respecting that many different
communities have many different
needs societal structures different
populations they need to reach
but the details are still unknown
including for family doctors who could
play a big role getting shots in
arms i haven't seen detailed plans
from the 34 public health units those
have not been made officially public
so i think as family doctors we would
welcome
that information with patients calling
anxious
for information abigail beeman global
news
ottawa the overall number of covid19
cases is on the decline in canada but
there are some red flags
and several pockets of bc alberta and
saskatchewan cases are beginning to rise
the rate of the spread is measured by
the reproduction rate or r value
when r is above one an outbreak can grow
exponentially
when it is below one it means the
epidemic is shrinking
with more contagious variants now
present in every province there are
fears exponential growth
could rapidly change the game heather
urex west explains
even with its pastor in custody the
grace life church outside edmonton
continued its months-long defiance of
alberta's public health orders sunday
holding yet another crowded service we
do see
these larger events that are very public
in defiance of restrictions but i think
we also tend to
under appreciate how many smaller daily
things are happening
which could explain why some parts of
western canada are now seeing covet
cases
start to rise in bc a 50-person
games night at a pub in the fraser
health region became a super spreader
event
15 people from that that event
which is against orders
became infected and spread to several
workplaces
to schools and to a child care center
when the reproductive value is
over one it means covet cases are
increasing exponentially
right now biostatistician ryan imgrid
has found the r
value above one in seven of ten
provinces
but its highest in bc's fraser valley
east of vancouver
northern and central alberta and regina
saskatchewan
it seems to be the start of something
and now really what it comes down to
it's how fast places can react
alberta is due to decide whether more
restrictions will be eased
next week but dr dina hincha says
current trends
are troubling especially with the
presence of the variant first discovered
in the uk
what i would say is that the variant
certainly
is established at a low level in our
community and we need to work together
to prevent it from becoming established
at a higher level
alberta has other problems too more
people are refusing to cooperate with
contact tracers
and fewer are coming forward to have
covet tests even as test positivity
rates remain
high when we're testing fewer people and
the positivity rate goes up it's really
concerning that we're missing
critical cases in the community all of
these pieces really are suggesting that
there is a storm
brewing a storm that very quickly could
get out of control
heather urex west global news calgary
blaming poor intelligence and each other
coming up
why didn't those in charge of security
on capitol hill anticipate
the violent riot plus a fireball erupts
after an
explosive crash
there is a blame game playing out in
washington tonight about the deadly
capitol hill riots on january 6th
a hearing is underway into the violent
siege and officials in charge of
security
testified publicly for the first time as
jackson proskow reports they are
pointing the finger at bad intelligence
and a delayed federal response these
criminals came prepared for war
they came with their own radio system to
coordinate the attack and climbing gear
and other equipment to defeat the
capital's security features
in chilling detail those tasked with
securing the u.s capitol building
described the highly coordinated attack
they faced at the hands of pro-trump
rioters
i received chemical burns to my face
that still have not healed to this day
after an impeachment that focused on the
words and actions of president donald
trump
the reckoning has moved on to security
lapses
during the attack as the capital was
overtaken washington's police chief says
the pentagon was reluctant to deploy the
national guard
concerned about the optics of using
troops and my response to that
was simply i was just stunned that you
know i have officers that were out there
literally fighting for their lives
the chief of the capitol police and the
sergeants at arms who have all since
resigned
insist they prepared for that day based
on the intelligence they had
we all believed that the plan met the
threat
and that we were prepared we now know
that we had the wrong plan
the day before the attack an fbi
intelligence bulletin warned protesters
were ready for war
what we got was a military-style
coordinated assault on my officers
and a violent takeover of the capitol
building concerned about our election
integrity
while to this day some republican
senators continue to deflect from their
own role
in pushing lies about a stolen election
floating discredited theories
that the mob was actually made up of
fake trump supporters
there is however bipartisan agreements
on the need to improve capital security
permanently at a hearing on monday
president joe biden's nominee for
attorney general warned the threat of
domestic extremism
is at its highest level in decades donna
all right jackson proskow in washington
thanks
deal reached ahead why facebook is
lifting its ban on news
in australia
this frightening inferno happened in
texas this morning an 18-wheeler
collided with a train carrying coal and
gasoline
the huge explosion sent dark smoke high
into the sky
at least one home was destroyed no one
was hurt
the cause is under investigation
australia has scored a victory in its
drive to make internet giants pay for
news and for the work of journalists
facebook has agreed to lift its ban on
australians viewing and sharing news on
its platform
the social media company struck a deal
with the government on a bill designed
to
force platforms like facebook and google
to share ad revenue with news outlets
last week facebook removed all news
content for its australian users that
provoked outrage
countries around the world have kept a
close eye on the dispute including
canada
there are reports the federal government
has agreed to coordinate efforts with
australia to ensure
social media companies here also pay for
journalism
doctors orders get outside next
prescribing nature
for healing
the duke of edinburgh will spend a few
more days in the hospital in london
buckingham palace has revealed prince
philip has an infection and is
comfortable in responding to treatment
but is not expected to leave the
hospital for several days
the 99 year old husband of the queen was
admitted to king edward vii
hospital a week ago well it's well known
that getting outside can be good for
your health
it's called forest bathing or ecotherapy
it's not an alternative treatment for
serious disease of course but it is a
healing idea
that is catching on robin gill explains
the west coast has the advantage of
milder weather than the rest of canada
so it's easy for carmen ruazi laza to
get up for a walk
rain or shine it's getting me into
better condition
not just physically emotionally
spiritually and
definitely mentally as well that caught
the attention of dr melissa lem
a family physician for more than a
decade she started writing
formal prescriptions for her patients to
get outside
why is a prescription better than just
telling your patient
well there is evidence showing that
written prescriptions are better
received
than just verbal advice at motivating
patients to make a change
during a patient call or visit dr lem
custom prescribes nature prescriptions
depending on a person's condition
whether there's a chronic disease or
mental health issues i think they
understand intuitively that nature is
good for them
and so sometimes it just takes that
little reminder from a physician
the prescription initiative recommends
two hours in nature per week
and one session should be at least 20
minutes because that's how long it takes
for stress levels to drop
british columbia is the first to start
this program in canada
ontario has now signed up the university
of calgary
and university of alberta are joining
forces on a study
that seems obvious to nature lovers
nature can be in your front yard it can
be in your backyard
you know there's great data out there
that says just looking at nature
is is enough to sort of calm that
parasympathetic nervous system and relax
you
and to refocus your attention dr lem
knows it herself
it's been said that doctors should not
self-prescribe but in this situation
would you self-prescribe
that's a good question i i think i feel
my prescription almost every single day
i make sure that i get outside for at
least half an hour into nature every day
and then there's carmen ruaz elaza she's
already in tune with the effect of
bathing in nature
it just calms everything down that
healthy dose of fresh air keeps her
coming outside for an hour
every day robin gill global news
vancouver
that is global national for this tuesday
i'm donna friesen well cute animal
videos can be good for the health too
and
there's no shortage of those here's one
police in charlottetown were called to
help this seal it was wandering around a
neighborhood obviously lost
the officers popped it in the back of
the car and gave it a lift
back to the sea it slid back to its
natural habitat
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
[Music]
bye
[Music]
you